[Music]
we tried to go to the airport but it was
almost impossible
to the airport about 10 or 15 times
you have tried i've been waiting here
for 48 hours
i'm running out of food running out of
water i'm in the canal and my wife and
kids were behind the canal my son was
unconscious he was
i mean
i was about to lose him
[Music]
monumental decision about america's
longest 20 years
when you move the chest piece on the
board somebody else moves into that
position who is
the stunning collapse of afghanistan
plays out in real time
we're ending america's longest war
i have worked for the u.s army two
infantry companies and one engineering
company the female journalist uh
since last five years our brother is an
american youth army every time i was
visiting the airport the taliban and the
checkpoints were just asking where where
are you going the talibans were checking
the passports the id package and i was
not able to show my password
because if they check my password they
know who i'm at it's called written in
there that i'm a journalist and my face
is like completely like this without a
job in my passport they will not accept
it the situation was so bad so bad there
were thousands of people thousands and
thousands of people there was
checkpoints of the talibans
and even if we go there
we didn't had a litter offshore letter
for evacuation so that we could be part
of that that was impossible for me last
time that i went there
i just i was very close to the marine
and the 82 second airborne uh troops
there and i stolen hey man i've just
worked for you guys
just
see my documents see my case numbers
have contacts in the united states i
know lots of congressmen and i know lots
of other people just see my documents
and they were just telling me we've got
orders not to let people in at this
certain time mostly
we spend their
nights also and if from one gate we
didn't pause we couldn't pause the
airport to get in we tried from another
door and from there also if we didn't if
we couldn't
so which tried
from another door also and i was like
i've been waiting here for 48 hours i'm
running out of food running out of water
i'm in the canal and my wife and kids
were behind the canal my son was
unconscious he was
i mean
i was about to lose him my wife was
hungry thirsty starving there was no
place to go to thailand and stuff so
finally resulting i did not make it in
the evacuation and i'm still left behind
we were
much cats and our family
our ladies also the taliban was fired
and
our children was escaped
we tried but
it couldn't happen we tried but it was
almost impossible
already we are thinking about a way to
get out of the country to find a way to
currently
contact
working with
my team members they're trying to find a
way
to get me out of here so for now
the only way is the charter sites we all
living for now
just for that hope me and my brother
we're just on social media searching for
the email address they're searching for
a country that could help us sending
emails but without any response actually
i'm just kind of looking into the
websites and talking to different people
in order to just
find something to help me out
we just wait and our brothers say that
every time
it's gonna happen in these days it's
gonna happen after one day or two days
so i don't know what's happening i know
he's trying the
uh his best but
it's not in hand
and uh hand and
we hope that the government who our
brothers have through the government of
the u.s and he spent his
sum of la or more of life
in u.s army maybe the government will
help a us army family i'm just hopeless
i'm just broke i don't i mean
for time being
we people don't have money even to buy
our groceries if we are not dying from
the threats of the taliban
we may die from the handler the world
has forgotten afghanistan and they left
us in this situation and
i can't tell you
how it feels to be in afghanistan right
now afghanistan have become
hell this country is not a place to live
anymore a scary life is so hard we just
wait
that when we will arrive to our home
our hope is that to live here with our
family
and come together with our mother
our brother and america together
inshallah
you